[Music]
it's a summers day in 2012 and I'm
working on a community volunteering
project with my team from work I'm
painting a room in a small rundown house
and my boss Chris walks in and picks up
a brush the two of us chat back and
forth for a while before the
conversation takes a turn in a more
personal direction hey what's your
girlfriend's name
he asks Alana and and what does she do
and then how long have you guys been
together his questions keep coming and I
do my best to respond to them but my
heart is beginning to be faster and
faster why well because my partner's
name is not Alana its Alan and in
responding to Chris's questions I'm
growing this complex web of lies
to disguise Alan and my sexual
orientation from the view of my
colleagues and it's tough to keep up
have I answered that question before and
am I saying something now which
contradicts the things that I've said in
the past it's honestly exhausting but
this is what would run through my mind
every time anyone would ask me a
personal question at work even something
as innocuous as hey how's your weekend
would send a shiver up my spine well it
doesn't take much to understand that
this left me feeling like an outsider at
work in addition to that it caused my
productivity to plummet after all I was
spending so much time and energy trying
to keep the secret that there was little
energy left for me to deliver at work
furthermore I was throwing up these
barriers between my colleagues and I and
I avoided building any personal
relationships with them at all this is
why it's important for us to talk about
inclusion
how we as leaders can foster inclusive
working environments for our teams but
what exactly do I mean by that well an
inclusive working environment is one in
which everyone feels respected and
connected to each other simple as that
now there's an ever growing body of
evidence which shows that LGBTQ people
who do not feel included in the
workplace are less productive and are at
greater risk of leaving furthermore
companies that do not appear to be
inclusive from the outside struggle more
to recruit LGBTQ talent and to give you
a sense of the numbers here by some
estimates there are as many as 16
million LGBTQ people in this country's
workforce alone 16 million now I'm a
Kiwi and granted New Zealand's a small
country but that's like four times our
population like in 2016 after I'd come
out at work I was building up an LGBTQ
employee network there and I approached
our security team to ask them whether
they were factoring in LGBTQ
considerations into their risk
assessments of new country entries you
see I worked in the oil and gas industry
and many of the countries that my
company was looking to move into how
particularly hostile views toward LGBTQ
people well that question led our
security team to realize that they were
sending or we're at least trying to send
LGBTQ people to countries that
criminalize homosexuality with
punishments of jail time and even death
now as a leader can you imagine coming
to that realization the realization that
your actions or the decisions that you
have made could unwittingly have put one
of your team members at risk that's a
scary thought now in front of me today I
see a bunch of young aspiring leaders I
see people who are going to have to deal
with challenges like this in the few
and who will be leading some of those 16
million LGBTQ Americans and countless
others from around the world and while
it's easy for us as leaders to focus on
the hard numbers in business if we truly
want to develop healthy high-functioning
cohesive teams then it's our
responsibility to focus on inclusion so
I'd like to leave you with three
challenges today my first challenge to
you is be mindful of the signals that
you are sending let's rewind a bit to
the story I told you about Chris and I
when Chris spoke to me about my partner
he used the word girlfriend it was a
phrasing he probably didn't think twice
about but it left me feeling as though I
couldn't be opened with him as though he
had some kind of like predetermined
ideal for what a team member and his
team would look like and that that was a
mold that I just didn't fit into had
Chris simply used the word partner or
something of that nature it would have
made me feel much more comfortable in
that moment my second challenge to you
is have the courage to make mistakes
when I came out to a colleague in at
work a couple of years ago his first
words to me were yeah I thought so he
then went to Google and typed in what to
do when someone at work comes out to me
and yeah I thought so was one of the top
things that Google said not to say
but hey I brushed it off and he didn't
allow it to discourage him himself
instead he used it as an opportunity to
learn and now when I asked how he would
respond to a similar situation in the
future his response is a simple
I appreciate you opening up to me and
that's a great start
my third challenge to you today is lead
with empathy now just for a second I
want everyone in this room to think
about your deepest darkest secret
something that no one else in the world
knows I want you now to think about what
it would feel like to tell someone that
secret for the very first time
your heart is absolutely racing and your
palms are sweating
it's literally a fight-or-flight
response this is how it felt for me to
come out to my manager back in 2014 so I
want you to put yourself in the shoes of
those who follow you and to think about
how they perceive you as a leader do you
lean into emotional situations like this
and look for an opportunity to connect
or do you shy away are you open and
approachable
someone to whom your team members can
really talk about anything or are you
closed off now I'll admit it's easy for
me to stand up here and offer you these
challenges in the liberal Enclave that
is the Bay Area and that there are some
parts of the world where I could be
prosecuted for just giving this talk
while I think it's important for us all
to exercise sound judgment I want to
remind you of one thing being inclusive
is simply about making people feel
respected and connected and how you
achieve that is essentially the same
regardless of whether you've got someone
in your team who is LGBTQ identifying or
whether there's something else that
makes them unique when I step back
and I put my myself in Chris's shoes
back in 2012 I can see that he was just
doing what felt natural to him at the
time but as leaders we need to
prioritize inclusion and put the needs
of our team members first so I challenge
you to be mindful of the signals that
you are sending to have the courage to
make mistakes and to lead with empathy
all in an effort to create healthy high
functioning teams and organizations so
my question to all of you now is are you
all up for the challenge thank you
[Applause]
[Music]